yeah it's time to impeach the
congressman who won't impeach Trump for
more than a year and a half the left has
been trapped in the tightening grip of
Trump derangement syndrome it's a fun
term but does it reflect a real
psychological issue more and more
psychologists say they're seeing the
symptoms specifically an overpowering
fear that President Trump represents the
end of the world I gather this started
with a Canadian Broadcasting Corporation
survey Nell Daly you're a
psychotherapist do you think Trump
stress trumped arrangement is a real
syndrome no absolutely not
and actually it didn't just start with
the Trump administration so any kind of
derangement syndrome when we've been
talking about presidents that started
during the Bush administration people
said that people had Obama derangement
syndrome and now they're saying that
people have Trump derangement syndrome
it's just a way of discrediting anybody
who disagrees with you essentially but
but let's let's break that down because
I remember the Bush derangement syndrome
I remember saying to some other time
basically george w bush he was a very
moderate republican he loved Mexicans
for example and like the president
present president 90% of the time he was
like Tony Blair with a ranch and yet
people convinced themselves he was like
the new Hitler now here we have a guy
who in some sense is an even more
untypical doctrinaire conservative he
doesn't care about transgender bathrooms
he doesn't care about race a lot of his
family are Jewish and yet he's
apparently the new Nazi he's
anti-semitic he's racist LGBTQ
communities are cowering in fear from
him what is it is it in the water is it
fluoride what's going on well I think
where it starts to break down is that
you need to trust your leader you need
to have faith in your leader as a human
being to have faith in their vision to
understand their vision so where the
dialog breaks down is if you don't have
faith in your leader you don't even want
to hear their vision and people
he's been tweeting that his opponents
people who don't submit political views
have Trump derangement syndrome so again
in any kind of argument you're having
with somebody it shuts off the argument
completely if you tell the other side
that they're crazy so just be just to be
clear of that now so you're saying that
when the when the president by the
president accusing the naysayers of
having Trump derangement syndrome he's
actually given them it no I didn't say
that I mean this this is just a term I
think he's necessarily I mean I don't
know I don't know whether in I mean it
sounds like when he's tweeting these
things he is diagnosing an entire
population of people but again this
doesn't just go this doesn't just happen
from Trump right it goes back to the
Bush administration this goes back to
people who disagreed with Obama let me
let me ask you about a point you just
made I thought that was interesting we
said you have to have faith in your
leader as it were this is a citizen
Republic where it chooses one of its own
citizens to be the leader that's why you
got rid of George the third there was a
guy because you didn't have a faith in
him he's like walking around with crowns
powdered wigs and you said no we're just
gonna have a citizen representative why
can't if you disagree with the president
why can't you just take the view that
he's just some bloke in in the office
for a couple of years and the pendulum
will swing and some other guy will be in
there in other words why let it ruin
your life I it's a good point and some
people do take that position not
everybody who has come to me or sits in
my office is upset about the current
president but there are a lot of people
who are so individuals handle it
differently but the point is is that to
show that we ran you're an evolved
person and a highly intelligent person
is open to intelligent nuanced debate
right and in our culture now we've
stopped having those intelligent nuanced
debates in part because we stopped
listening when we're told that we're
crazy to have a difference of opinion
from the person that we're discussing
anything with yeah but but it's not the
president who drives someone to climb
halfway up the Statue of Liberty and
start going bananas is it I think that
there are people who would disagree with
the
and I think they're people who would
disagree with you that that's
necessarily a banana way of protest okay
well I'll see you up there
I don't know whether I'll make it to the
top but I'll get 2/3 of the way see you
up there Dowell thanks very much